today we'll be ranking the top 20
strongest characters in Jujutsu Kaizen
we'll start with one of the strongest
calling game players hiromi and in later
parts of the video we'll be covering
some of the legendary characters that
are in a completely different League
compared to everyone else homi was
originally an ordinary non sorcerer and
a defense attorney however when the
coling game started he became an
impressively strong sorcerer in only 12
days not only did he become this
powerful in less than two weeks but he
also learned how to use his domain
expansion deadly sentencing during the
coling games he was the first one to
reach 100 points among all the players
which means he killed at least 20 other
people this is even more impressive
considering he wasn't actively searching
for people to kill he only killed those
who came after him since homi is
considered a genius his fighting style
also reflects that with his domain
expansion revolving around debating and
tricking the opponent instead of violent
allout attacks after each character
we'll also speculate how strong they'll
be at the end of the series and you'll
definitely be surprised by some of the
results since homi isn't expected to get
any new powerups his place will most
likely stay the same number 19 AI Toto
Toto has a high degree of cursed energy
and a really good understanding of how
to utilize it making him arguably the
strongest grade one sorcerer in the
series we first saw his powers during
the kilo Goodwill event where he and
Yuji fought against tanami although
Hanami was a special grade Cur Spirit
Toto held his ground pretty well and
even found the time to tutor Yuji during
the fight showing just how much
confidence Toto has in his abilities
even though he never awakened domain
expansion like Karama I'd argue that is
Boogie wogie more that makes up for it
using this ability Toto can switch the
position of anything with cursed energy
within his range simply by clapping his
hands this pretty much means he can just
teleport himself and others however he
pleases when he and Yuji fought against
awaken mahito during Shibuya Toto was
forced to avoid all of mjo's attacks as
well as a bunch of transfigured humans
at the same time all while helping Yuji
land attacks on the curse even when he
lost his hand he was still able to
outsmart mjo and help yui land a
finishing blow on him however this
injury means that Toto can't perform his
signature technique anymore and that's
why his place at the end of the series
will stay the same number 18 mumi
fushiguro mumi is a first year at Tokyo
chuai and one of the characters with the
highest potential in the entire series
at one point even Gojo stated that mumi
could become as strong as him one day
mumi inherited the 10 Shadows technique
a prize technique passed down in the
zening family which allows them to
summon up to 10 shikigami to a him in
battle during the death painting Arc
mumi decided to go all out and let his
imagination flow freely opening his
domain for the first time Kimera Shadow
Garden this domain floods the area with
fluid Shadows that can rapidly produce
any shiky gami mumi Desires in addition
to Shiki gamis mumi can now also produce
clones of himself from the shadows and
if he focuses hard enough he can even
produce a subscribe button Out of the
Shadows okay that last one's maybe not
true but you should definitely click it
thank you anyway later throughout the
story mumi took on many strong opponents
like Reggie star and was even able to
save his fellow Sorcerers from deon's
domain expansion it's evident that mumi
has a lot of potential which sukuna
displayed well by using his techniques
if mumi survives the current events in
the story he'll definitely emerge much
stronger number 17 Yuji itadori Yuji is
one of the jiujitsu high's most valuable
assets and the first human who could
control sua within him despite having no
connections to the jiujitsu world Yuji
was able to become an incredibly strong
sorcerer with only 2 months of training
to the point that he can now contend
with and defeat grade one and even
special grade curses even without the
usage of cursed energy Yuji has inhuman
strength as he can destroy walls with
ease and also throw cars once he learned
to control cursed energy his most
powerful attack became a technique
called black flash in order to use it
Yuji has to connect an impact of cursed
energy immediately after landing a
physical hit this will create a spatial
Distortion and make his attack around 2
and a half times more powerful some of
yuji's biggest achievements as a
sorcerer at battling against choso and
makito and although sua played a part in
each of these battles Yuji still managed
to hold his own against these insanely
powerful curses as the show's main
character Yuji will definitely get a
huge power up at some point point and
possibly surpass some of the strongest
Sorcerers in the series putting him at
around eighth place number 16 choso
choso is one of the incarnated curse WB
death paintings which pretty much makes
him half human half curse while still
existing as a cursed object choso was
self-aware allowing him to Hon his curse
techniques for 150 years josa mostly
uses blood manipulation to fight and
other than Kaku he's probably the
strongest user of this ability in the
series his feets speak for themselves as
he would surely win against Yuji if
mamaru didn't interfere he defeated
naoya and even tenen chose him as a
bodyguard over Yugi and mumi and don't
even get me started on how impressive he
was in his fight against kinjaku all in
all choso surely deserves his place on
this list number 15 Dagon and Hanami the
four unregistered special grade curs
Spirits are all unreasonably powerful
which is to be expected considering the
fact that they're created from
Humanity's Collective fear of natural
disasters however the four of them are
not equal and that's why the 15th spot
on this list goes to Dagon and Hanami
Hanami is a cursed spirit with a
powerful technique that allows him to
control plants and an uncanny ability to
hide his presence he's so good at this
that he even managed to catch Gojo by
surprise on the other hand dagon's
ability allows him to generate and
control water even two grade one
Sorcerers working together namami and
naito weren't able to successfully
exercise Dagon and instead almost got
killed by him however in the end despite
their strength both Hanami and Dagon
were the first special grade curses to
die Hanami was ruthlessly overpowered by
Gojo while Dagon was quickly killed by
toi also their domain expansions
ceremonial sea of light and Horizon of
the captivating scanda didn't really get
much screen time so in order to keep it
simple I'll put them both of the 15th
spot on the list since both of these
characters are already dead their place
at the end of the series will obviously
stay the same number 14 Ru and uro these
two are very close to being special
grade Sorcerers meaning that the curses
mentioned so far should pose no problem
for them both Ru and uro are Sorcerers
from long ago reincarnated by Kaku to
participate in the coing game the
Striking thing about Ryu is that he had
the highest cursed energy output out of
any other player in the culling game as
for Udo she was the leader of a group of
elite assassins during the Golden Age of
jiujitsu both of them have really
impressive curse techniques Rio can
shoot directed blast of cursed energy
while Udo can turn the sky into a
tangible surface and manipulate space
this definitely wasn't an easy fight for
UTA and considering how strong he is
that's saying a lot about uro and ryu's
strength it's also important to mention
that both of them have domain expansions
but because they used it at the same
time as UTA the barrier came apart
before any of the three domains could be
fully realized number 13 mahito the
scary thing about mjo is that he can
easily take out most of the characters
in the story because of his Idol
Transfiguration it's a curs technique
that grants him the ability to reshape
Souls doing so allows him to disfigure
the body of his victims or heal his own
wounds basically One Touch from him and
it's over for your everyday sorcerer mjo
is also the only special grade curse
whose growth we actually get to see he
learned his domain expansion self-
embodiment of perfection in a matter of
days and when he saw Gojo use unlimited
void for only2 seconds seconds he was
immediately able to replicate it when he
finally realized the true essence of his
soul during the Shibuya Arc he instantly
got much stronger and he took the
combined efforts of Yuji and Toto to
finally bring him down mahito had the
greatest potential out of all special
grade curses probably because he was
spawned out of people's fear and hatred
towards each other Which is far stronger
than any of the fears of natural
disasters number 12 Joo sometimes I feel
bad about Joo he's obviously incredibly
strong but his opponents were Gojo and
sukuna which is just cruel
however there's a reason Jugo only
fought these two monsters it's because
he far outclasses most other sorcerers
in the story since Jugo was spaed out of
people's hatreds towards volcanic
natural disasters his powers also
reflect that with him being able to
produce highly concentrated cursed
Flames he also has a domain expansion
coffin of the Iron Mountain which is
pretty broken as well but what truly
separates him from the other three
special grade curses is the fact that
even suuna the king of curses himself
told him that he was strong and this is
a compliment sukuna doesn't hand out
lightly just remember how he treated mjo
during their encounter number 11 Maki
zenim although Maki started off as an
average strength sorcerer that quickly
changed during Perfection preparation
arc when Ma sacrificed herself in order
to help her get stronger after Ma's
death Maki obtained the body of Steel
and all her senses were Amplified to the
point that she could sense changes in
air density and temperature while she
was rampaging through the zening clan
she was able to pretty much on-shot both
Ogie and janichi two special great first
class Sorcerers and none of the Clan's
strongest Fighters had any chance
against what happened at the zening clan
that day wasn't a fight it was a
complete Slaughter since Maki already
had a major power up recently I doubt
she'll get much stronger than she
currently is so her place at the end of
the series will most likely stay the
same number 10 toi fushiguro the source
of her killer even though toi's and Maki
strength are on a similar level now toi
has a way better understanding of curse
tools and has more combat experience due
to him hunting Sorcerers his entire life
he was the only character in the whole
series able to win against Gojo not only
that but he was also able to
effortlessly defeat get though who was
considered Gojo's equal at the time
toi's strength lies in him possessing no
cursed energy this makes him
undetectable by other jiutu sorcerers
which allows him to move through
barriers unnoticed and even sneak past
Gojo's six eyes technique this also
helps his unpredictability in battle and
causes others to underestimate him based
purely on cursed energy however with
that said toi isn't invincible and can
easily lose to the top tier Sorcerers
like the one we're going to talk about
next hajim kosimo just like Rio we
covered earlier kosimo is a sorcerer
from over 400 years ago however the main
difference between him and Ru is that
Kashima was actually the strongest
Sorcerer of that era this is already
enough to earn him the spot on this list
as it pretty much puts him in the same
league as Gojo and sukuna who are both
the strongest Sorcerers in their eras
kashima's cursed energy has the
properties of an electric current
putting his body in a constant state of
electrification this makes his
reinforced physical attacks impossible
to defend against as his hits shock the
opponent upon impact although we haven't
yet seen kosimo inate curse technique
since he's saving it for suuna it's
surely incredibly powerful another
interesting thing is that we didn't see
Kimo's domain expansion I mean shouldn't
the strongest Sorcerer of anera be able
to cast The Domain it seems there's
still much about Kimo's Powers we don't
know about however one thing is clear
his electrified curse energy and
Lightning Charge won't be nearly enough
to go against sakuna so we'll have to
wait and see what he does next number
eight kji hakati the thing about hakati
is that he's not graded but considering
how highly Gojo thinks of him it seems
that hakati has the potential to rival
Gojo one day I think it's safe to say
that his strength is comparable to
special grade sorcerers after all he did
defeat kosimo which says a lot but what
exactly is it that makes aati such a
tough opponent to deal with his domain
expansion idle death gamble this domain
allows him to create an environment
resembling a train station that hosts a
game of chance aa's primary goal is to
line up three of the same numbers to hit
the jackpot with only a 1 in 239 chance
of doing so however hitting the jackpot
puts sakati into the unkillable mode
this gives him unlimited curse energy
for 4 minutes and 11 seconds the exact
duration of private Pure Love Train
theme song which plays through
throughout the round during this time
period any injuries he experiences are
immediately healed making him quite
literally unkillable I'm sure aari will
eventually be classified as a special
grade but until then I can't put him
above any of the real special grade
Sorcerers number seven Yuki sukal Yuki
is an extremely powerful fighter as well
as Toto's mentor and the first special
great sorcerer on the list Cate
technique is called star rage and it
allows her to Grant virtual mask to
herself in her shikigami Garuda this
mask can enhance her attacks and give
them devastating destructive force
capable of effortlessly defeating even
the special grade curses I'd consider
Yuki the weakest out of the four special
grade Sorcerers simply because the story
didn't focus on her as much as it did on
the others her only real battle was
against kinjaku and even though she put
up a good fight she ultimately wasn't
able to defeat him if she is dead which
seems to be the case it would be really
unfortunate as we didn't even get to see
her domain expansion however if by some
miracle she turns out to be alive and
shows us more of her powers she can
definitely move up a few spots on the
list probably to fifth place number
number six suguru ghetto ghetto was
initially a classmate of Gojo and shoko
at Tokyo jiujitsu High while there he
was known as one of the strongest
Sorcerers of his generation and the only
one who could rival Gojo however over
time his experiences as a sorcerer bred
a deep hatred for non Sorcerers leading
to an incident where ghetto massacred
over a 100 civilians in a single night
he was expelled from jiuai and came to
be known as the worst of all curse users
and one of the biggest threats to modern
society as for what makes him so strong
it's his cursed Spirit manipulation
technique that allows him to consume and
manipulate curs Spirits the maximum
output of this technique is called
Uzumaki and it combines a massive number
of collected curses into one powerful
attack we've seen this attacking ghetto
battle against UT and R where he used
thousands of curses at the same time
although ghetto eventually lost that
fight he'll undoubtedly be remembered as
one of the strongest curse users in
history number five yosu yosu is one of
the strongest Sorcerers from the hon era
which is considered to be the Golden Age
of jiujitsu her entry in the story was
rather abrupt but I think it's safe to
say that she outclassed classes both
Yuki and GTO Yo's Ina curis technique
allows her to recreate any substance she
recognizes creating something from
nothing uses a lot of cursed energy
which makes this technique way more
draining compared to other cursed
techniques she also has a domain
expansion and it's called three-fold
Affliction in this domain yosu can use
the sure hit effect of the domain and
hit the target with any item she's
constructed it may not look that
impressive and is probably not among the
coolest domains but it's pretty
effective even though sukuna wasn't
taking her too seriously and eventually
won the fight using only 10 Shadows
technique she did pretty well against
him considering sukuna had the power of
15 fingers at that point although we
don't know how some of the other
characters like Kashima would Faire
against sukuna for now I think yuru
deserves fifth place on this list number
four UTA otu UTA is currently a
second-year student at Jutsu high and
like GTO and Yuki he is one of only four
special grade Sorcerers uta's immense
cursed energy comes from his genetic
relation to mijan sugat one of the big
three vengeful spirits and an ancestor
to both him and Gojo Yoto is also able
to manifest ra a a special gr vental
Spirit known as the queen of curses
although this is already pretty
impressive he also has an insanely
powerful innate technique called copy
this allows him to copy other sorcerers
inate techniques and use them himself he
can even use multiple different
techniques that he's copied in quick
succession with his immense cursed
energy and R's help UTA has defeated
some of the strongest characters in the
series like ghetto uro and Ryu another
thing that separates him from the rest
is his excellent understanding of the
reverse curse technique which allowed
him to pretty much bring Yuji back to
life after killing him currently UTA can
only utilize R for 5 minutes but with
time he'll probably be able to do it for
much longer considering this and the
fact that he has the most potential out
of any sorcerer his rank at the end of
the series will probably be a bit higher
at third place number three Kaku kinjaku
is an ancient curse user who's lived for
over a thousand years using his innate
technique which allows him to transplant
his brain into other people and control
them he's inhabited different
individuals throughout the centuries and
assumed their identities some of the
bodies he inhabited are niosi camo kiori
and most recent recently suguru ghetto
since he's inhabiting ghetto body Kaku
can also use ghetto inate abilities like
Spirit manipulation in Uzumaki what's
even more interesting is that he can
extract Ina cursed techniques of spirits
he consumes and store them for one-time
uses this is how he was able to use Idol
Transfiguration after consuming mjo
although not confirmed kaku's reverse
curse technique is probably among the
strongest in the series as he's had to
heal his Target's bodies after
transplantation on top of all this
kinjaku also has a domain expansion
called womb profusion which looks like a
giant pillar made up of cursed Spirits
the effects of this domain are still
unknown now although Kenji was the third
strongest character in this series the
last two characters are in a completely
different League compared to him and one
of them is the strongest Sorcerer of the
current ERA Gojo satoru as soon as Gojo
was born it was said that the balance of
power in the Jutsu world had shifted he
was the only sorcerer in a very long
time to be born with both Limitless and
six siiz techniques the strongest
combination of abilities in the entire
story while he was still a student he
suffered his only loss against toif
fuigo but since then Gojo has kept
getting more and more powerful and now
stands at the very Pinnacle of jiujitsu
leagues above everyone else although
gojou has many cool abilities the most
impressive one is his Infinity this
technique is constantly active and it
makes all incoming attacks infinitely
Slow Down When approaching Gojo making
him pretty much Untouchable like other
top tier Sorcerers Gojo has a domain
expansion called infinite void which
when activated traps the opponents in an
infinite flow of information making them
unable to think or move Gojo is proved
time and time again why he's the
strongest by effortlessly defeating Joo
battling multiple special grade curses
at the same time in shibba and most
recently holding his own against the
king of curses himself sukuna before we
cover the strongest character in the
entire Juju suuk kaisen there are two
characters I want to briefly mention
Angel and Tangen both of these are
undoubtedly among the strongest ones in
the series and definitely deserve a spot
on the list however due to very limited
information about them I'll leave them
as honorable mentions for now which may
change as the story progresses number
one Roman suuk the king of curses
according to the legend sua was an
imaginary demon but in truth he was the
strongest jiujitsu Sorcerer of all time
also known as the disgraced one during
the Golden Age of jiujitsu many
Sorcerers gave their all against him but
ultimately fell one after another sukai
existed throughout the ages by
transforming into a cursed object after
death a state where he split his power
into 20 indestructible fingers there is
so much about sua we don't know heck we
don't even know what his innate
technique is however we did get to see
his domain expansion malevolent Shrine
which is portrayed as a buddh shine
decorated with skulls inside it sua's
opponents will get relentlessly slashed
over and over again until nothing is
left of them sua had a few really cool
battles throughout the series but the
most impressive one is by far his
current battle against Gojo although the
battle seems balanced for now with both
characters holding their own it seems
like sua is plotting something and not
using his full strength yet anyway we'll
have to wait and see how this plays out
but for now sua takes the top spot on
the list click on this video where we
explained all of Gojo's forms in
jujutsukaisen
oh